If I was to host a hypothetical
head-to-head tournament to determine
the most evil serial killer of all
time, who do you think would win?
The safe money would be on history's homicidal
heavy hitters - Jack the Ripper, Ted Bundy,
Jeffery Dahmer. But if you had to bet your entire
life savings on one individual, you could do a
lot worse than back the man often referred to
as America's first serial killer - HH Holmes.
During a reign of sheer terror in Chicago
in the late 19th century, Holmes is thought
to have brutally murdered more than 200
people at a rate of more than 40 per year.
Many of his victims met their maker in a house
of death that came to be known as the murder
castle. Built to a labyrinthine plan that only
Holmes himself understood, the sprawling complex
was full of secret passages, trap doors, and
soundproofed torture chambers. Holmes lured
hundreds of innocent people to this morbid mansion
with murder on his mind, and after killing them
in the most horrific ways imaginable, some were
dissected, others were stripped of their flesh
and sold to medical schools as skeletons, and
still others were melted in giant vats of acid.
When you take into account the volume and sheer
brutality of his crimes, it's hard to imagine
anyone can rival HH Holmes for the title of the
most evil serial killer ever to have lived...
...but there's a catch. You see,
almost nothing I've told you about
HH Holmes so far is actually true.
Don't get me wrong, I didn't just make it up.
Every single detail - the sky-high body count,
the castle of death, the dissections and
torture chambers - it's a matter of public
record. The staggeringly gory story
is the subject of newspaper articles,
encyclopaedia entries, and multiple documentaries.
Which makes it all the more strange
that the entire thing is utter nonsense.
This is the confusing tale of HH Holmes,
America's most misunderstood murderer.
Holmes was born under the rather less enigmatic
epithet of Herman Webster Mudgett on the 16th of
May 1861 in the town of Gilmanton, New Hampshire.
Almost nothing is known about his early years.
Some sources claim he had an abusive alcoholic
father and that his favourite childhood pastime
was to torture the local wildlife, but those
are just rumours with no documented evidence.
Mudgett married at the age of just 17 to the
first of what would eventually be 4 wives,
though since he never bothered actually divorcing
any of them we can add bigamy to
his soon-to-be long list of crimes.
Mudgett was never a particularly strong student,
but he managed to scrape his way to a medical
degree from the University of Michigan, and it
was there that we hear rumours of his earliest
crimes. Despite his reputation as one of
America's most notorious serial killers,
Mudgett's first felonious forays didn't
involve *creating* cadavers, but selling them.
In those days, corpses were a
surprisingly valuable commodity,
sold on the black market to medical schools for
anatomical research. And Mudgett was only too
happy to dig up the deceased from the local
cemeteries in order to make some fast cash.
...Or at least, that's what several sources claim.
Again, there's no real evidence to prove he was a
bodysnatcher, but that probably shouldn't come as
much of a surprise. I'm no criminal mastermind,
but if I was in the business of selling
corpses, I probably wouldn't write receipts.
We *do* know that body snatching was
relatively commonplace at the time,
and Michigan university was a bit of a hotspot.
There's also the probably-not-coincidental fact
that after his execution some years later, Holmes
was so worried someone might come along and dig
up his remains that he asked to be buried in
a block of solid concrete 10 feet underground.
So yeah, there's a fair chance this
particular Holmes rumour is actually true.
After graduating in 1884, Mudgett worked
several odd jobs across the American northeast,
gaining a reputation as a bit of
a womaniser and a lot of a conman.
Two years later he moved to Chicago, where
he restyled himself under the now infamous
pseudonym of Dr. Henry Howard Holmes - HH
Holmes to his mates. Most historians agree
the name change was designed to stop the various
people he'd swindled from tracking him down, but
I‘m guessing he was probably also just a bit sick
of having a name like a squib from Harry Potter.
According to the traditional tale, on arriving
in Chicago he found work at a local pharmacy,
where he eventually murdered his boss
to seize control of the business.
In truth, Mudgett - well, Holmes - bought
the drugstore fair and square. Far from
being Holmes' victims, the previous
owners outlived him by several decades,
a fact that's proven by the dates on their
headstones which still survive to this day.
Between the pharmacy and a growing list
of illegal activities, Holmes was fast
becoming a wealthy man. So he did what any of
us would do with a bit of spare cash - he bought
an empty plot of land and started work on a
giant death factory (we've all been there).
This grand building you see before you, known
today as the 'murder castle,' was the result.
Now, if you happen to be especially observant,
you may already have noticed that this infamous
'castle' looks suspiciously like a fairly
standard mixed use commercial building.
And it turns out there's a pretty good
reason for that - that's exactly what it
was. There were shops on the ground floor
and apartments above. Holmes added a third
storey in 1892 which he planned to use
as a hotel, but it was never finished.
In 1893 Chicago played host to a World's Fair
- a 6-month bonanza that attracted a staggering
27 million visitors. Probably the most famous
element of the commonly told HH Holmes story
is that he built his murder castle to take
advantage of this huge influx of tourists.
In the era before people posted 450 social media
updates every single day, tourists were vulnerable
- their friends and relatives often had little
idea of exactly where they were at any one time.
So, according to the story, Holmes built his
murdery mansion as a way of ensnaring large
numbers of hard-to-trace World’s Fair visitors
- preferably young women ripe for murdering.
That all sounds fairly logical - well, if you’re
a serial killer - but it turns out that Holmes
started building his 'castle' several years before
the Chicago World's fair had even been planned.
Admittedly work on the third floor did roughly
coincide with the announcement of the Fair,
but we can be fairly certain he didn't
lure any young women there for Netflix
and dismemberment because the hotel
part was never actually finished.
Several people were indeed murdered on the
premises - more on that in a minute - but the
whole 'murder castle' concept is total nonsense.
The original architectural plans for the building
don't show any secret passageways, trap doors, or
purpose-built torture chambers, and the building
simply wasn't big enough to have enclosed
the complex labyrinth later accounts claimed.
Almost all these wild stories came from the
press after Holmes was finally brought to
justice a few years later. It might sound
unlikely that journalists could have gotten
the details of the case so incredibly wrong,
but Holmes' capture happened to coincide with
the heyday of what's now known as yellow
journalism - a style of reporting where
newspapers just made everything up to sell
more copies. Why does that sound familiar?
But while there's no evidence the building
was some kind of murder metropolis,
it *was* used as the base of operations for a
wide range of less gruesome cons and schemes.
To put it simply, if HH Holmes believed
something could make him money,
he was already doing it. During his criminal
career he's known to have forged checks,
stolen horses, bought expensive items on credit
with no intention of ever paying off the loans,
and defrauded a wide variety of insurance
firms in multiple ingenious ways.
But while he wasn't the mass murdering
maniac most people think he was,
Holmes was still a killer - and a pretty
prolific one at that. We know for sure
that he murdered 4 people, and there's a
good chance there were at least 9 victims.
The first is thought to have been Julia Connor,
the wife of one of Holmes' employees, Ned.
Holmes and Julia started an affair in
the early 1890s, and when Ned found out
he quite understandably quit his job
and moved away. Not long afterwards,
Julia and her daughter Pearl went
missing, never to be seen again.
We don't know for sure what happened to them, but
Holmes later claimed Julia had fallen pregnant,
and that she'd died when he attempted to
perform an illegal abortion. It's generally
assumed he killed Pearl because she knew too
much about the circumstances of her mother's
death and therefore represented a dangerous
loose end. Julia's remains were never found,
but the body of a girl of about Pearl's age
was dug up in Holmes' cellar after his arrest.
5 months after Julia and Pearl went missing,
Holmes struck again in incredibly similar
circumstances - he started a relationship with one
of his employees - Emeline Cigrande - before she
suddenly went missing. Once again, Holmes
claimed a botched abortion was to blame.
In retrospect that man probably
shouldn’t have had a medical licence.
The following year two more women
with ties to Holmes disappeared,
Minnie and Nannie Williams. As with all the
others, the details are sketchy, but it's
thought Holmes scammed them out of some property,
then murdered them before they had a chance to
go to the police. Much like Julia Connor and
Emeline Cigrande, their bodies were never found.
There are plenty more stories about people turning
up at Holmes' 'castle' never to be seen again,
and several of them are quite possibly true.
But convincing evidence is extremely thin
on the ground and it's likely we'll never
know exactly how many people Holmes killed,
though there’s zero chance it was
anywhere near the commonly circulated 200.
By 1894, he'd swindled (and murdered) so many
people in Chicago that he decided it was probably
best to move on. He travelled first to Fort
Worth, then St. Louis, and it was there that the
law finally caught up with him. Considering he was
very probably a serial killer at this point, It’s
almost laughable that Holmes was jailed for the
heinous crime of failing to pay off store credit.
Remarkably it was his first stint in jail,
and while he didn't stay behind bars for long,
his brief incarceration kicked
off a chain of events that would
eventually lead to him being hanged for
murder... but I'm getting ahead of myself.
While in jail, Holmes met a man
by the name of Marion Hedgepeth,
better known as the Handsome Bandit. Handsome
Hedgepeth was a Wild West gunslinger who was
serving 25 years in the slammer for train robbery.
Both being colossal bastards, Holmes and Hedgepeth
soon struck up a friendship, and between them they
cooked up a scam with a potentially huge payoff:
Holmes was going to fake his own death.
If you're wondering how pretending to die
could possibly be a get rich quick scheme,
I've got two words for you: Life Insurance.
Holmes was bailed not long afterwards and
he promptly put the plan into action. We
don't know exactly how he staged his own death,
but we do know the insurance company
became suspicious and refused to pay out.
Holmes was undeterred. He knew he could pull
the scam off if only he could make things a
little more convincing. But faking your
own death isn't like fighting Malenia in
Elden ring - you can't keep trying over
and over and over and over and over and
over.... again. And that meant Holmes
needed to find someone else who was
willing to fake his own death in return
for a slice of the life insurance pie.
That man was his long time business
associate and literal partner in crime,
Benjamin Pitezel, and their
plan was pretty simple.
Step 1: Take out a fat life
insurance policy in Benjamin’s name
Step 2: Get hold of a dead body
of about his size and build
Step 3: Blow said body up in a planned explosion,
making sure it gets good and burned in the
process to conceal its original features.
Step 4: Report the death
Step 5: …Profit
The only question was, how to make sure the
insurance company wouldn't see through the
ruse. Holmes had already discovered just how
hard they were to fool… but that experience
gave him an idea - what if he didn't
have to fool them in the first place?
As you've probably already guessed,
rather than risk using a random corpse,
Holmes simply murdered Benjamin Pitezel
so he could make the claim for real.
Pitezel’s wife had been in on the scam from
the start - she was the one who needed to
file the claim with the insurance firm - but
she had no idea her husband had been double
crossed. She went through the entire claims
process - including identifying the charred
remains of her dearly beloved - all while
believing he was really hiding out in London.
Of course, there was only so long that
deception could last - sooner or later
Mrs Pitezel and her children were going to
want to see their husband and father again.
But Holmes wasn’t worried - by
this point in his career as a
professional arsehole he had plenty
of experience tying up loose ends…
Along with Benjamin, to keep his secret safe
Holmes murdered 3 of the 5 Pitezel children.
Two of the girls - Alice and Nellie - were
forced into a large trunk which Holmes filled
with asphyxiating gas, while one of the boys -
Howard - was poisoned, dismembered, and burned.
The Pitezel family killings are the only Holmes
murders we can be sure he committed - not only
did he confess to the crimes after his
arrest, he gave detailed descriptions
of how and where they took place, and he also
told police where they could find the remains.
Thankfully, those were the final murders HH
Holmes would ever have the chance to commit.
Because his old prison pal the Handsome
Bandit had been doing some talking.
It turns out Holmes had bragged about
all manner of evil deeds while locked
up with Handsome Hedgepeth, and the train
robber had decided to use that information
to buy himself an early release. He
told the police everything he knew.
Holmes was arrested in Boston on the 17th of
November 1894. Despite his numerous crimes,
a relative lack of evidence meant he was tried
solely for the murder of Benjamin Pitezel.
But that alone was more than enough to see him
given the death sentence. On May the 7th 1896,
HH Holmes was hanged. When the trap was
sprung his neck didn't break, and he was
left twitching at the end of the rope for a full
20 minutes before finally being pronounced dead.
As I've already mentioned, we have some highly
questionable 19th century journalism to thank
for many of the more outrageous
stories told about HH Holmes today,
but it’s worth pointing out that Holmes himself
is responsible for much of the confusion.
Before his death, Holmes admitted to
killing 27 people. The confession,
delivered straight from the homicidal
horse's mouth, should have been pretty
solid evidence. But things were never that
simple when it came to HH Holmes. Not only
did Holmes’ version of events contain
several contradictions and revisions,
he also claimed to have killed several people
who turned out to still be very much alive,
and several others who were known to have
died of natural causes hundreds of miles away.
As for what his motive was for confessing
to crimes he didn't commit, your guess is
as good as mine. Some people believe
he was deliberately trying to fan the
flames of his own legend before his death,
while others think he was trying to confuse
the prosecution during his trial. Perhaps he
was just a few sandwiches short of a picnic.
Even now, almost 130 years after his death,
mystery continues to swirl around HH Holmes.
Along with the widespread misinformation about
his life and deeds, a decades-long conspiracy
theory claimed that Holmes didn’t really die
in 1896. Instead, according to the theory,
he pulled off one last trademark scam,
escaping his own execution by convincing
someone else to ‘take the fall’ in his place.
The rumour gained so much backing that in 2017,
his remains were exhumed from their
concrete tomb for examination.
Thankfully, genetic testing proved conclusively
that the one thing HH couldn’t cheat was death.
Thanks for watching.